another day dawns over the swiss canton
of valais above the village of listen ye
at an altitude of 1400 meters are 15
white pods
zabelinha beylin bold and t le biaggi
head up to their tent from the reception
area in the parking lot they have to go
on foot in snowshoes snowmobiles will
bring their things up later on they've
booked a short stay in the pod after all
one night costs more than some upscale
hotels between 300 and 400 70 euros
depending on the amenities and number of
guests we only live once and for me this
is something very exclusive something we
don't do every day we're celebrating our
6th anniversary and so we want something
very special you can't put a price tag
on that kind of thing yes you only do
this once and I think we'll remember
this always but just getting to the pods
is something of an experience and an
effort
however the 20 minute climb is well
worth it
the reward is a breathtaking panoramic
view of the valley and Lake Geneva
and the tent is cozy and preheated and
they're surrounded by Nature the couple
are overwhelmed I'm more surprised than
I thought I'd be I think we'll see the
stars tonight that'll be very romantic I
can't wait to see what it's like so far
it's all been very positive the
operators have put lots of attention
into furnishing the 40 square meter pod
tents and the guests do sleep in a real
bed
the lamps armchairs and tables are
supplied by a local tradesmen all in all
little remains of the raw camping
experience
every pod has its own shower with water
delivered from Hot Springs guests also
have their feet kept warm over the
double bed is an upper-level with room
to sleep two children a staff of 15 look
after the facilities and the guests
well-being
Julie's Bob Lata has been the general
manager for two years now what we want
to offer to our guests is peace comforts
when our guest comes to white but to
just to just see something which is
unique in the world that just relax to
just forget about everything they just
think of the nature we can say they can
hear the silence the tents were designed
in the United States a steel geodesic
dome provides stability against the wind
and snow
a wood stove provides heat retained
inside by triple insulation the staff
keep the stoves burning during the day
but at night the job is up to the guests
you can heat the pot inside up to 25
degrees easily the thing is that you
still have to wake up during the night
otherwise it's going to be pretty cool
in the morning but that's part of the
experience of white buds and actually
people like it after sunset the guests
can retire to their tents or dine in the
resort's own restaurant nearby
after a long exhausting hike through the
snowy winter woods Selina Balin bold and
chilly bajji enjoy a traditional Swiss
fondue the perfect end to a perfect day
now they're hoping for a clear night
with a view of the Milky Way from their
cozy abode